Казали: "Ти зі "спідозніком" зустрічалася - тобі взагалі норм?
Людей сьогодні вбиває не ВІЛ, їх вбиває стигма - люди бояться піти зробити тест, розповісти комусь.
Телеведуча Христина Шапран живе з ВІЛ чотири роки, а 22-річний підприємець Данило Столбунов - від народження.
Вони - одні з 250 тисяч українців, які, за даними Центру громадського здоров'я, інфіковані ВІЛ.
80 тисяч із цього числа навіть не знають про свою хворобу, а багато хто приховує її через страх цькування.
Тим часом раннє виявлення ВІЛ і сучасна терапія, яку можна отримати безкоштовно, дають інфікованим можливість жити повноцінним життям.
У мене стався роман. Людина зняла презерватив, а мені про це не сказала.
Тобто у мене був незахищений секс - і я лише потім про це дізналася.
Через місяць у мене виникла ангіна, яка супроводжувалася висипом.
А ще через деякий час я намацала у себе збільшені лімфовузли.
Перевірилася у лікаря. Медики кажуть: "Слухай, п'ять збільшених лімфовузлів - сходи-но ти до фахівця".
І я така: "Я знаю, що це". Тому що знаєш - пазлик склався.
Коли мені сказали про мій статус, мені було років вісім чи дев'ять - точно не пам'ятаю.
Це було через рік після того, як мій батько помер від СНІДу.
Мені мама про це сказала. Насправді я відреагував на це нормально - мені навіть стало трохи легше.
Я не багато знав про ВІЛ, але здогадувався, що це він - особливо останніми місяцями, тому що ми ходили в СНІД-центр.
Але в мене не було в голові всього цього - СНІД, смерть, труна, кладовище...
Ну, ок, ВІЛ, п'ю собі таблетки. Мама просто пояснила мені, що ці таблетки доведеться пити дуже довго - можливо, навіть все життя.
Паніка була в однієї моєї подруги. У неї знання про ВІЛ були на рівні газети "СНІД-Інфо" 90-х років.
Для нас було дуже зворушливим, тонким моментом, коли ми сиділи у кафе, і вона в сотий раз мене питала, а я в сотий раз пояснювала,
що ВІЛ не передається через слину, і що навіть секс без презерватива зі мною можливий, і все буде гаразд,
адже я на препаратах, я безпечна і так далі - просто не треба так робити, чисто для спокою.
Я пам'ятаю момент, коли вона бере ложечку і починає їсти моє морозиво моєю ложечкою. Це був прямо знак - все добре…
Я вступив до медичного коледжу.
Моїх одногрупниць викладачі залишали після пар і розмовляли з ними, проводили бесіди - мовляв, ви знаєте, що у вас є позитивний хлопець у групі?
Якось поступово люди почали говорити про ВІЛ, і я зрозумів, що вони говорять про ВІЛ через мене.
І раптом я розумію, що мені це подобається - не те, що говорять про мене, а що взагалі говорять.
Що є цей діалог, і мені не доводиться ховатися і видавати себе за когось іншого.
Таким чином я прийшов до того, що мені взагалі немає сенсу приховувати це.
Так, я ВІЛ-позитивний - всю групу вдалося якось проінформувати.
І чудово - мені напевно пощастило, група поставилася нормально, і зі мною навіть найгарніша дівчина потім зустрічалася цілий рік.
На цьому, звісно, такі історії не закінчувалися.
Потім, коли з цією дівчиною я припинив зустрічатися, до неї підходили з паралельних груп: "Ти зі "спідозніком" зустрічалася - тобі взагалі норм?..
Чому я наважилася говорити? Тому що всі мої розмови про ВІЛ закінчувалися фразою:
чому ніхто не пояснює так, як пояснюєш ти?
І я стала людиною, яка може пояснити так, як пояснюю я:
агов, це просто хвороба, так буває, вона не гірше, ніж ваш карієс або ще щось...
Ну так, насправді гірша, але якщо з нею адекватно поводитись, якщо адекватно ставитися до себе, то все буде нормально.
І мені здається, що людей сьогодні вбиває не ВІЛ, їх вбиває стигма -
що люди бояться піти зробити тест, розповісти комусь. Просто через ті страхи, які існують у суспільстві.
Коли я був малим, я пив багато різних пігулок, капсул, ще й сироп - дуже гидкий на смак.
Це було перше або друге покоління препаратів. Кожен раз, коли я ввечері приймав ці препарати, мені ставало дико хріново - так, що жити не хотілося.
Нині я три роки сиджу на останньому поколінні препаратів.
Одна пігулка в день - я почуваю себе прекрасно, немає ані безсоння, ані чогось іншого, взагалі реально не помічаю, як вітамінку випиваю.
Одна таблетка на день. І все.
Єдине, що іноді складно не забути, тому що, коли ти п'єш не перший місяць і навіть не перший рік, то це стає такою автоматичною штукою.
Знаєш, як виходиш із дому, зачиняєш двері на ключ, а потім не можеш згадати - ти зачинив чи ні.
У мене таке з таблетками.
У мене стоїть три будильники, тому що буває так, що будильник дзвонить,
ти на щось відволіклася, вимкнула і вже не пам'ятаєш, випила ти ці таблетки чи не випила.
Іноді це складно і потім стає страшно, блін - а я пропустила чи не пропустила?
Якусь кількість ще можна пропустити і начебто нічого страшного не буде.
Але ти так один раз зробиш, потім другий, третій - а потім у тебе раптом виникає резистентність, і потрібно міняти схему лікування, а схем обмежена кількість.
Ти розумієш: якщо у тебе в планах прожити ще років 50, то, напевно, краще так не робити.
Як реагують?
Я якось навіть з дівчатами знайомився на вулиці, і мені не потрібно було розповідати, що у мене ВІЛ,
тому що вони до цього десь бачили ефір зі мною.
Ми потім починали зустрічатися, і все було нормально.
Але насправді з більшістю профілактичну роботу проводити треба.
Тут не так, як у Німеччині чи Нідерландах, на кшталт "I'm HIV-positive" - "А, оk, аlright. You take your treatment, that’s all".
У нас треба пояснювати, що є лікування, що вірусне навантаження на нулі, що нікого заразити не можу, що все ок.
Були ВІЛ позитивні, які мені казали: "Слухай, спасибі за те, що ти про це пишеш, бо я не можу дозволити собі так говорити про це".
Мовляв, я десять років з ВІЛ, і тільки двоє людей навколо мене знають про це - моя мама і мій брат, приміром.
І таких людей безліч. Це люди, які ховають себе заживо.
Які говорять: у мене ніколи не буде відносин, у мене не буде нормальної роботи, вони себе відрізають від усього.
Я намагаюся сказати: Агов, не треба, це не ВІЛ ставить на тобі хрест, це ти сам ставиш на собі хрест. Навіщо?
Має бути нормальна звичайна розмова: як і про сексосвіту, як про медичний канабіс, про ЛГБТ.
Було би прикольно, якби у нас - як у парламенті, здається, Великобританії - з'явився політик із ВІЛ.
Це буде саме той резонанс, який трохи струсоне наше інформаційне середовище, а люди скажуть:
"А, ну, значить норм". Якби президент привітався з ВІЛ-позитивним політиком або, наприклад, прем'єрміністром,
я думаю, це зняло б величезну кількість проблем і стереотипів.